hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast economies of scale in
cannabis moving from lab scale co2
supercritical fluid extraction to
production scale presented by the lit
tortilla the president and CEO of thark
energy I'm Suzy Valdez elaborate and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen type your
questions into the drop Docs that appear
on that screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the help desk
button located on the promotional board
at the bottom center of your screen or
use the ask a question box to let us
know you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits please join me now in welcoming
dr. Georgia I will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome sir
good afternoon thank you for that
introduction I appreciate it and welcome
to all of you
this is lull in Saudia I'm the CEO of
thought process and today I want to talk
about supercritical fluid extraction in
particular but in general cannabis
extraction we'll start off with a
background on thought and course
experience in supercritical the
different extraction techniques that are
out there and we'll follow up with
issues related with scale and scale up
supercritical both on the extraction
side and also on the purification side
but those who do not know what's
supercritical is you'll see a slide on
the right-hand side and at the extreme
right you will see a point which says a
critical point as long as you operate
out the critical pressure and the
critical temperature you're in the
supercritical region that is what we are
working with here now if you look at the
horizontal line at the critical point as
long as you are above this point and
horizontally you can decrease the
pressure you can increase the
temperature you can play with all of
these parameters to get the right
extraction conditions you need or the
process you're trying to do now at the
very end I'll summarize with all the
lessons that we have learned today so to
give you back the history of
supercritical here in 1982 we started a
company called super X we were the first
supercritical company in the whole world
so you can see the background we have
been doing this for the last 35 years in
Super X we developed instrumentation
specifically focused on extraction and
chromatography we launched the first
capillary SFC in the world and
ultimately the company was sold to Isco
in 1990 I started far in 1990 in 1990 we
started working on various equipment for
supercritical but not the analytical
site we made pilot plant and production
scale onwards you know we went on to
spin out number of divisions from tar
and we started building large-scale
systems and we have built over 20
production scale I'm talking about 500
liter thousand liter systems in the last
ten years between 2007 and 2010 we have
done a number of different things we
built a prep scale SFC on words build
the largest act colonists have seen in
the world
we built a counter-current column going
up to 30 feet long where he can do
separations instead of using a
chromatographic separation we can use a
counter-current separation then in 2011
we built a large facility at the back of
our building that we are located today
it is a 25,000 GMP facility where we
extract astaxanthin which is a
antioxidant from algae called America
blue Wallis and late last year we
doubled that capacity so right now we
are one of the largest if not the
largest algae producing company in the
world over here algae extract essay
using supercritical fluids the
extraction pressure is fairly large
you're talking about 15,000 pounds of
pressure so it's one of the highest
extraction systems in the world onwards
we have moved into also making
chromatographic separation equipment
which is HPLC and SFC we do both
depending on the sample and we have
built a 600 mm which is a 24 an inch ID
column three of them for a
pharmaceutical company overseas so we
have a strong background in both
extraction and chromatographic
separations the mission of thought
process is to be a global leader in
supercritical fluid technology and
equipment by providing solutions
involving involving chemistry design
process development and optimization we
take our customers from concept through
commercialization our competitive
advantage in this critical area we are
the most experienced supercritical only
company we have been doing this for the
last 35 years we didn't start this a few
years ago when the medical marijuana
extraction market came into force
we have been doing supercritical long
before people on green tea
nology was fashionable from a design
point of view we bring all the different
process and equipment telic technologies
together we manufacture our own
equipment so we put things together
which is optimized solutions based on
the initial feasibility studies all the
way through production and all systems
as I mentioned earlier and major
components are designed developed and
assembled and one warranted by our
process and this is all done out of
Pittsburgh
Sylvania lastly we are customer centered
partnerships from proof of concept
through commercialization or their
production solution of choice so we are
very customer friendly company so the
examples of work that can be done with
supercritical is you can do polymer
purification you can remove solvents
from synthetic DNA astaxanthin from
algae you can do a less intense recovery
of residual specialty oils extraction of
spices flavors fragrance fragrances and
any active ingredient from herbs in
short if the wood oil is used we can
probably extracted from the natural
product besides extraction supercritical
can be used for reactions impregnation
scouting so there's a variety of
applications that you can use it for and
if you are trying to make specialty
products using these cannabinoids you
can use the impregnation technology to
do it for any kind of applications you
might have the what I'm going to start
off today is talk about different
extraction technologies there are really
five of them out there you can do with
ice water which is one of the oldest
techniques where you take your
cannabinoids you take your plant
material grind it up put it in ice water
and since THC and CBD and all the
cannabinoids are heavier they settle
down on the bottom it's a very simple
process but the overall extraction
efficiencies you can
use hydro cam solvents like propane
butane hexane these are all nonpolar
solvents very similar to supercritical
co2 but the disadvantage of these they
are highly explosive so you have to have
explosion proof requirements and there
are a lot of regulate ratios and how
much you can have these solvents at your
building and you know constraints
associated with that and that is a you
know always a worry of explosion so you
have to be a little careful about the
other technique which is the RSO which
is similar to the hydrocarbons but
instead of using propane butane and xane
you're using naphtha or isopropyl
alcohol the process is still very
similar the other extraction solvent
which is becoming popular these days is
ethanol ethanol is significantly more
polar than co2 so the kind of compounds
the selectivity is very different the
ethanol is a very good solvent because
it is physiologically compatible but
again from a regulatory point of view
there are restrictions on how much you
can use so if you're trying to scale
this it becomes a regulatory nightmare
to handle methanol on a scale the last
of course that we are talking about
today is supercritical co2 and we
believe supercritical co2 is great
solvent and the question is why and if
you look at the list here first we start
with it's a zero global warming
potential it's a zero ozone depletion
potential physiologically compatible
it's inexpensive and available
everywhere you're talking about one
hundred and fifty dollars a ton which is
really inexpensive and the most
important is he does not need any
explosion proof requirements so you can
almost put it up anywhere the other
advantage of supercritical is by varying
the temperature and pressure you can
extract different things and by running
a low temperature extraction you can get
high selectivity but the negative of
load
Reiter extraction is that you have a
high solvent to feed ratio so you have
to run the co2 that you are using for
now you know about a factor of 10 in the
same overall extraction efficiency on
the other hand you can increase the
temperature so you can do high
temperature and high pressure and you
get a very high efficiency of extraction
but the selectivity is low so you end up
extracting things like waxes which you
have to remove further and but overall
the solvent to fade ratio is low which
means you get high productivity so there
is advantages and disadvantages of any
of these things that you do you have to
look at the pros and cons decide what is
the right thing for you now in a typical
process you can see the schematic on the
left-hand side of the screen you have a
pump where you can pressurize the
vertical co2 and it goes you preheat it
then it goes into the extraction vessel
you extracted you depressurize it and
you collect it in a separator and the
co2 comes out and you recycle so the
major components here are pumps vessels
and separators these are the three major
components that govern the scale of
issues and you can get these vessels all
the way down from you know one liter
five liter to as much as 500 liters or
larger depending on who you go to now
when you come to sizing the important
question you have here is how do you
determine what size you need when you do
scale up the first and foremost question
that comes here is what is the solvent
to fade ratio you do that trials on a
lab scale 5 liter system and then
determine what's the solvent to feed
ratio the reason this is important is as
I mentioned earlier I'm preacher and
pressure play a major role in the
extraction so if you are doing low
temperatures you may need a solvent to
repay ratio of e 120 and if you do high
pressure and high temperature the
to feed ratios so solvent to feed ratio
controls your sizing so that's the first
thing you need to know once you know
solvent to feed ratio you define what is
the capacity you're going for is it in
kilos at a 100 kilos a day at Sun a day
what is the capacity and based on the
capacity and the solvent to feed ratio
they'll get you a number which is the
total amount of co2 that you need on a
daily basis and the next question
becomes once you have this number
whether you're doing this in a 8 hour
time frame or a 24 hour time frame you
can calculate the pump flow rate so we
start with the basic thing here pump
flow rate defines your capacity it does
not the vessel size which is what
everybody thinks it is actually the pump
flow rate if you have a small pump and
you put a little and if you even double
the size of the vessel it doesn't mean
that your capacity has gone up because
the capacity is controlled by what is
the flow rate of the pot so that is the
most critical thing from a scale a point
of view is defining the pump flow rate
which is a function of the solvent to
feed ratio and the capacity that you
need
once you define the pump flow rate then
you what you do is you design the vessel
diameter and the vessel diameter is
defined by the linear velocity of this
flow rate inside the vessel if you have
a very large vessel diameter and you
have a very low linear velocity and if
you have a very small vessel diameter
you have a very high linear velocity if
you have a run high linear velocity the
herbs or the plant material will go to
the other end of the vessel and get
stuck potentially plugging it so you
want to make sure you have an optimum
and there are numbers that we use over
here typically in the range of 20 feet
per second
so we use those to calculate what the
vessel diameter should be once we do the
vessel diameter we define the vessel
size by determining the vessel length
and that gives us the total diameter
total volume of the vessel between e
lastly this what I want to mention here
is the subcritical co2 extraction which
has high solvent afid ratios will force
you to use a vessel which has a very
large in diameter which obviously
increases the cost because of the
pressure while the supercritical
extraction which is high-pressure
high-temperature has much lower solvent
to feed ratios so you come up with
sizing for a large scale or on a scale
of issue now I can show you some vessel
equipment that are available in the
marketplace the one on the left that you
see typically a water's pro provides
five liter systems to ten liter systems
the one in the middle it's medium scale
you can get them from apex and one on
the right is a large scale system and
this is 750 liter to vessel system so
total of 1500 meters this one actually
operates at 15,000 pounds of pressure
that I talked to you earlier about and
we extract astaxanthin so this is our
system at our facility in Pittsburgh so
you can get variety of sizes and you
need to size them based on the previous
slide that I showed and come up with the
size that you need so again talking
about scale up issues over here how do
you calculate cost here's from our
experience we say capital cost is y
power X in other words if you had to
double the size so Y is a factor of two
and we power it to point six eight then
the capital cost will go up by one point
six so it's not linear it's not a
logarithmic the power is typically
powerup point six eight so every time
you double the size you can assume the
capital cost goes up by a factor of one
point six typically the utility cost is
a function of flow rate which largely
remains the same on a per pound basis
when you process it so you don't get
much reduction by going a scale up maybe
about three percent for every doubling
of the flow rate so you don't get a
substantial reduction on utility casting
and finally you come to labor the
unfortunate part of labor is labor
remains the same whether use you use a
five liter system or a hundred liter
system or a thousand liter system so
labor becomes the largest portion of
your cost and as you scale up labor
becomes a smaller portion of the overall
overall cost so it's very critical for
you if you want to drive the overall
cost down to scale up and scale up to as
large scale as possible the the other
way to design your system is to have
different configurations the basic
system is you have one vessel and one
pump and that simple straightforward you
have a vessel a pump and a separator you
are done that's what most people sell
you can go from here and say how do I
increase my Cassity you can have two
vessels and one pump and while the first
one is running you can load the second
vessel vessel get it ready and get it
moving and that will give you a 30%
increase in capacity that's a typical
number sometimes it's a little high
sometimes it's a little low it all
depends on what your total extraction
time is shorter the extraction time
greater effect it has longer the
extraction time less effect it has so
you can
who from a one vessel to a two vessel
system and all you are doing is adding a
cost of a vessel and couple valves and
that immediately increases your capacity
by about thirty percent the next thing
you can do is a see this configuration
this is very interesting so what do you
do what you have here is three vessels
and two of them are connected in series
and you have only one pump so the same
pump that you used in the first two
configurations you can use in the third
one and this co2 will go from the first
vessel to the second vessel and because
you have two vessels in series you have
the highest extraction efficiency in
other words if the first in the second
one gave you a 80% extraction efficiency
for the same conditions problem you'll
definitely get more than 80% it could be
85 it could be 90 it's a function of the
application but it's the highest you can
get and while the first two are running
the third one is being unloaded cleaned
and loaded back again so then then you
switch and you take the second one out
put the third one in front of the first
one and you continue the process and you
continue this every time so you will be
able to get the same 30% as the previous
one but your overall extraction
efficiency will be higher and you'll
come out with more material the material
that you're looking for that's important
and the other option here is you can
have three vessels and two pumps
actually and that will double the flow
rate or you can have one pump with 2x
the flow rate and you can get 2.6 X
which is the highest extraction
configuration from that point of view
the last one is you can do a parallel
configuration which is two vessels and
two pumps which is literally double of
the basic configuration that you see up
there and that will get you to X the
capacity but the only
doesn't give you is the highest
extraction efficiency which the serious
configuration kills so you can play with
these things depending on what your
needs are and come up with the right
configuration and the costing for each
one is obviously very different the
basic configuration and the parallel
configuration are literally twice 2x and
the capital cost will be 2x from that
point of view and the most expensive is
the three vessel one pump with two
Explorer eight that will be the most
expensive capital configuration but it
also has the highest capacity so we use
these different configurations to define
what our scale-up are and what our
configurations are to get to where we
want to get you now the practicality is
we believe that there's going to be
market consolidation so far we have had
a lot of people doing mom-and-pop
operations with small systems as the
market grows you will find that people
with scale are going to win because
labor is one of the largest portion of
the overall costing which when we talked
about in couple slides ago whether you
have a 5-liter system or a hundred meter
or a 500 liter system you need the same
amount of labor so if you want to drive
the overall costing down you reduce
labor as a percentage and the only way
to do that is by going scale now this
has been shown to be true for other
nutraceuticals and here are just three
examples whether it's fish oil or Co Q
10 or astaxanthin in all of these things
scale wins and people end up moving from
small-scale systems to large-scale
systems and we expect this to be the
same even for the canvas industry now
the question becomes the next question
becomes is when you get to scale are we
better off contracting or be better of
doing
tassels that's a function of scale like
in so the question if I do have to
repeat the question should everyone whom
they're SFE or will be less expensive to
send it out to LA scale processors now
in the whole food industry especially in
the cannabis right now we do not have
major regulations because cannabis is
not looked well upon by the FDA but as
soon as the regulations change you can
expect significant regulations coming
down to follow cGMP requirements for the
extraction and once you say you have
cgmp requirements for your product you
have a ton of quality control procedures
that you need to fall typically you may
have three to five people dedicated to
follow this cGMP requirements and as a
percentage if you have a small
operations they become very very
expensive
it also requires you to have in-house
expertise or all the different things
whether you need a mechanical engineer
to maintain the equipment a chemical
engineer to run the process or quality
control people analytical people and
especially if you want to anything that
says we need certification we need cGMP
certification we need kosher
certification halal certification
organic certification all of this
requires significant amount of paperwork
which drives the Casta should say kosta
so what are our options our options are
threefold right so you can have a co-op
style for ethanol exchange the
extractions of corn oil and canola oil
you can see a number of farmers join
together and they built their facility
and that facility ran that on to extract
the oil or canola to the oil you can do
the same thing and we expect some of
these to happen in the industry the
other thing we also see is people will
bring in
while units will bring them to your
facility and they will run it and they
will run it because they have all the
expertise which comes along with the
mobile units so they'll run it produce
the oil the oil that you want whether
it's winter ice oil or refined oil or
even the unrefined oil any of those
things they can provide that for you so
you will have places where people will
drive in and attract one or two trailer
trucks and provide these mobile units to
process at your site and of course the
last one is you'll find people who are
set up large-scale contract
processing facility where you can send
the material to them and they will
process it and send it back to you and
they have all the quality control people
the engineers everything to manage it so
it on a per kg basis it could
potentially drive the cost down so those
are the three options that you have
besides you building it yourself and
maintaining it now when you go from
extraction to purification it's the
knowledge is even more critical than
extraction chromatographic separations
require a greater technical knowledge
but the scale of issues are similar to
extraction the regulatory issues are
similar and so we have little ease the
same scale of issues that we talked
about for the extraction site what you
see on the slide here is a prep scale
system with three separators for a Croma
drain a supercritical fluid
chromatographic system and what you see
on the right is the largest tack column
for supercritical fluids built by car
and it's in Malaysia they use it to
separate the oils from palm oil so if
you want if you're looking to do
multiple kilograms per day then the
first question that comes is you need a
large diameter column and these columns
are available all the way from a
just to 24 inches and the pressure
ratings on these columns have to be in
the range of 175 to 300 bar and the flow
rates of co2 and who solvent typically
in this case is ethanol range as little
as 5 kilos and memory to as much as 15
kilos so those are the typical
specifications for a multiple kilograms
per day of chromatographic product and
then the scale scalar parameters are
very straightforward if you double the
diameter of column the total amount that
you can process is typically 4 times and
the productivity is directly
proportional to flow rate selectivity
which is very critical for
chromatographic it's a function of
particle size smaller the particles you
get a greater selectivity but the cost
of the particles the chromatographic
particles go up so you need to do an
optimization typically we suggest
something in the 10 to 15 micron range
our probably the ideal particle size
from a cost performance basis our speed
capacity and selectivity are very
closely interrelated in chromatographic
systems you can get high-speed high
capacity and high selectivity if we want
all three of them then it the cost
quadruples so you have to optimize this
to get these solutions that you're
looking for lastly I have couple slides
here which I'd like to conclude my talk
and talk about what lessons we have
learned today
the first one is sizing is a function of
solvent to feed ratio the capacity of
the pump the capacity of the system that
you want we are looking for the pump
flow rate the vessel linear velocity and
all of that so those are all
interrelated and you start with the
solvent to feed ratio as a tea you get
the rest of the kilometres subcritical
extraction is very selective it's a
great way to do it but it has a very
high solvent to fade ratio and a lower
efficiency so you have to pencil what
kind of product you're looking for and
if you're looking for winterized oil
critical extraction is a good way to go
without going through a thermal
extraction and the packet the
supercritical extraction has a much
lower solvent to failure ratio typically
a factor of 5 to 10 less than the
subcritical extraction it gives you a
higher extraction efficiencies because
you're running at higher temperatures
and pressure but it extracts waxes and
other unwanted products so what you have
to do is once you extract this you have
to go to a conventional winterization
using ethanol and that cost time and
money so your it's a trade-off whether
you want subcritical or supercritical
extraction sometimes a good solution
might work you may want to do a
subcritical extraction to get a clean
winterized oil and then go back and
change change the pressure to a higher
pressure and higher temperature go back
and extract what's left to work so you
overall you get higher efficiency and
you get two products one is a winterized
oil directly the other one is where you
have to do anything it's an all
extraction and produce of interest oil
and quite a few people will take both
these oils and mix them together to get
a complete spectacle spectrum oil so
those are the things in this V I'm going
to summarize by saying we do expect
consolidation to happen we expect as the
market grows you have larger and larger
people coming in to play both internal
for their own needs and also external
for working with other people so
large-scale extraction will be the norm
as we go in the future many group will
either set up their
wherever they think they have the
technical capability and the money to do
it so they don't have to send the
material but that does not work for
everybody
they'll have mobile extraction units
which will come to your facility to do
this high-technology extraction as a
service at your site or you can go to a
toll processor who will provide you the
same service at their facility so you
have all of these options and you can
expect every one of them to be in be a
solution for what you are trying to do
and depending on what you would like to
get at the end of it you can pick one or
the other of course if you can if you
have the money the best is to set up
your own large-scale extraction unit
because you can control everything you
can control what you are trying to
extract the technology and it's all
internal but that might not worker
forever for everybody in that case you
might be better off going to an outside
facility or the last one is as I
mentioned earlier a group of people can
join together create a co-op and run the
coop for all their shareholders so all
these options are available and with
that I would like to conclude and say
our process will be happy to be an
extraction and purification partner and
if you have any questions please feel
free to let me know and I'll be happy to
answer I do very much for listening to
me today thank you dr. tortilla for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of this
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type the question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button will answer as
many questions as we have time for so
let's take a look
our incoming questions from our audience
our first question doctor Sharia is at
what point is it better to subcontract
instead of purchasing the extraction so
I would say it's really a trade-off
between capital investment and
subcontract costing setting up a
facility especially a large one requires
a lot of handling and people all of
these cost money and time it's always
cheaper especially in the short term to
subcontract the extraction and the
purification this gives you the ability
to go to different vendors and when your
volume gets very large then you can
think about setting up your own facility
because by this time you have learned
the business you're making money and you
have the time and money to invest in
your own facility optimizing to the
products that you want thank you doctor
Sharia and this next question from an
audience member is two-part question is
supercritical co2 extraction process too
complicated and do I need highly
technical people to handle that yes or
no the process is fairly simple but
because it is high pressure it requires
the use of properly designed products
and caution when you using them in other
words if you have nuts and bolts
tightening you have to tighten them so
you really have to take care to do this
properly you cannot be them circle about
it you can also think of the process
based on the raw material and that
requires a technical understanding of
what you are trying to do so is it
complicated yes it's a little bit
complicated but if you have the right
people you can handle it
thank you and I want to remind our
audience members that any questions not
answered today will be answered via
email our next question is
is there any use for the left over Rafa
to raffinate I think that's a very good
question that is many ways to figure
this out the simplest one is you dispose
it off or you burn it and you can take
the heat that generator to produce hot
water or electricity
so that's thermal energy that you can
get from your raw material but the more
interesting thing is because the
cannabis plant is a high fibrous plant
and it's been used for years - in
textiles and ropes it becomes a great
substitute or paper or text in textiles
so you can find these upcoming new
applications for the leftover material
which if you had to set up a plan to do
it it just makes good economic sense and
it gets a faster return of investment
thank you for that before we close dr.
Sharia do you want to provide the
audience with any closing remarks I I
just want to say that supercritical co2
is a great shoe you know as I mentioned
earlier you cannot get a better solvent
it's physiologically compatible it's
inexpensive if you know how to handle it
you should use it you can use it
efficiently it can be very selective it
just makes the whole process go easy and
you're not polluting the environment
thank you again dr. Shar dia for your
presentation and your important research
I'd also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before I go I want to remind
everyone that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
June 2018 you'll get an email from
laborat the swipe cast will be available
for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thanks for
joining us we hope
see you again soon bye-bye thank you all